four years ago Omar al-bashir moved into
the new presidential palace ignoring
those who criticized the opulence while
his people lived in poverty he's moved
again of course this time to prison the
palace now in the hands of the country's
military leaders Sky News met the head
of the military council general Abdel
Fattah albarran inside where he insisted
the military will hand over power
despite the skepticism of many here we
see a Fiat Aliya Miller medleys a
scaramouche toric o Mauricio de varville
some of the opposition's say that
members of the council don't want to
hand over power are they wrong but you
would like to see it as soon as possible
though we've reached this stage because
of this popular revolution led by young
people boys and girls who risked or lost
their lives demanding a transfer to
democracy it's not done yet so their
protest goes on the general promised
that they are safe and he will listen
[Music]
yeah stay quiet you date you're happy
for them to stay there you won't be
moving the barricades I know the
military council has said they needed to
get the roads open indicted war criminal
former President Bashir is wanted by the
International Criminal Court for now
he'll remain locked up here in the
future where what do you see happening
to him will he face trial here if he's
committed any crimes will you hand him
over to the International Criminal Court
and what charges do you think he will
face
[Music]
Annabella has led to Hermann mo jelly he
was the theater was near la camisa
Karnataka house led him to him either
amia with us today of course many in
Sudan seriously doubt that the
transition will actually happen but
general Boren has gone very public now
and if he reneged on his promises it
will not be forgotten
still Ramsey Sky News Khartoum